hi everyone my name is Lydia Gibson and
I'm really excited to be here in front
of you all today talking about a
community that's really near and dear to
my heart so today I'm going to be
talking to you about how the r for data
science online learning community made
me a better
student
now a little bit about me
I just graduated with my masters in
statistics this past May and
then and the following months I began
working at Intel as a data
scientist and it's a career I never
imagined myself in the same way I never
imagined myself standing right in front
of you all today giving this talk at
posit comp and the reason why
is I wanted to be a fashion designer
when when I was
younger yeah so growing up my
grandmother used to make matching
outfits for my sister and I and I loved
clothing and so in my teens I used to
sketch outfits that I would want to wear
um taking inspiration from magazines
like 17 and Teen
Vogue and I even designed my own prom
dress which my grandmother constructed
for me I don't actually know it or so
but
eventually um but yeah so when I started
out on my journey as far as changing
careers
I had no experience programming I'm
actually 31 I returned to school in my
30s to get my
masters and I didn't have experience
with statistics for the most part no
former programming experience and and I
didn't care about
R but unfortunately it is a necessary
evil if you're going to go back to
school for um statistics and I imagine a
lot of you also may not have cared about
r at some point um but yeah it's you
might not have cared about it but you
did care about the things you can do for
it whether it's statistics biology
something
geospatial eventually you did care about
it and for me what made me care about it
was Data
visualization so in data visualization I
was able to like feed my need for like
that creativity while also still
learning things that were relevant to
what I was doing in my
coursework
and kind of like what Megan mentioned of
How It's Great To to learn when you're
doing something that's fun it's also
great to learn when you have friends to
learn with and luckily I was able to
find that in the ARA data science online
learning community so pictured here with
me is John Harmon and he is the chief
Community manager and data scientist of
the arford data science online learning
community
and him along with his merry band of
mentors and facilitators of which I am
one they've created this amazing
welcoming learning environment mostly
based in slack where beginners and
advanced folks alike can come together
and learn various topics not necessarily
only related to R but just data science
as a
whole so for me with my interest peaked
in data visualization
the most likely choice for me as far as
book clubs was the ggplot 2 book club
and there in that book club it was me
sorry uh statistics programming and data
Vis newbie and I'm there with folks who
are our consultants and actuaries and
PhD students and there's little old me
so honestly it was terrifying the same
way I'm somewhat terrified up here right
now but because the way the art
community is and our
Fords it
was It was kind of easy to transition
into it so for me with my impostor
syndrome and just nerves I decided I'm
just going to jump right into it and I
presented chapter 3 and actually it's I
just had my 2-year annivers of my first
presentation and yeah it was it was kind
of a basic our markdown beer
presentation but I did it and I got
really great feedback and everyone was
so welcoming and I was just I fell in
love with that Community because I was
able to move past that fear get out of
my comfort zone and then get in a
Learning
Zone
so and yeah
so by merging my love of like fashion
design with data viz I was just
yeah I was just like in love and really
into it so I was able to take the things
I was learning in my book club and put
it towards um works I was doing in
classes um being able to not only use
like the utility of things you can do
and basar but taking Gigi plot too and
giving my visualizations a little bit of
pizzazz putting a little bit of myself
into my
visualizations and obviously the same
way in arford DS where
it's you're able to get help from folks
I was able to take my visions of what I
wanted for my visualizations and with
the help of my friends especially my
friend Ken um be able to create these um
be able to create these visualizations
that like were in my head and then put
them on the
screen and then even through aridus I
learned about like the various extension
packages you could make with um ggplot 2
and Just A Whole New World opened up for
me and I also learned about the data
visualization society and did a
mentorship program just feeding my need
for that
creativity um and following that
I I eventually ended up doing another
book club facilitating a data Vis data
visualization with our book club um by
Rob kabakov and even was able to bring
in my friends and teach them things that
I had learned and through that learning
reinforcing my learning as well um yeah
so then I guess I'll leave you with a
couple of takeaways I know this is very
short um but yeah it's kind of like
finding what you're passionate about and
exploring its depths especially as
someone new to the field of Statistics
or data science there's so many tools we
could learn and honestly it's
overwhelming so if you can just take
that one thing that you're passionate
about and explore its depth you can
learn so many more
things and then being surrounded by
folks more advanced than you is a gift
it's not a curse it can
be scary it can be overwhelming and you
have the sense of impostor syndrome but
if you look at it as the opportunity
versus that vulnerability it opens up so
many more doors for you for example me
even finding out about the data
visualization
society and then teaching is the best
way to learn I've honestly learned so
much by facilitating book clubs and just
um facilitating book clubs
and having to teach others the things I
know and just it being
reinforced um so this is my friend Ken
and my unofficial motto I suppose is
always be
networking and yeah I'm like a broken
record when it comes to my friends
telling them this and it's just because
I know how great communities like rord
DS our ladies and generally the our
community in general is that I think
it's so important for folks to get
involved and hopefully my talk may have
inspired some folks to get involved in
rrds um if you want to join it's
arras.io jooin if you want to be a
mentor
ar. ijoin and ping John
the and also if you want a sponsor to
keep communities like this going so
people like
me so people like me can learn and
somehow become data scientists like they
never envisioned
so thank
you
all right thank you so much Lydia so we
are taking questions in slid which you
probably all know at this point but just
a reminder so one question so
far what advice would you give to
someone who's new to R but doesn't know
where to start or what they're
interested in R seems vast and
overwhelming to explore discuss it
is um so where to start as far as
starting within the arford Das online
community I actually made a repo so in
that third link I have a repo about
information about joining your for your
first R Fords book club and I've
included things like downloading R the r
Studio IDE or even getting to posit
cloud and then because rord DS with our
book clubs we use GitHub um some intro
stuff as far as learning GitHub and just
checking out our slack there's so many
topics when it comes to our there's
shiny there's
geospatial anything you can think of and
just kind of search within there I would
say Okay fantastic thank you so much
let's thank Lydia
[Applause]
again